Transcriber: nada kilany
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
الحقيقة تقريبا كل الموجودين هنا جابهم
سمة مهمة
من سمات الجنس البشري،
وهو فضول المعرفة.
من أهم السمات اللي ميزتنا كبشر
إن إحنا عندنا فضول
شديد جدًّا للمعرفة، الفضول بدأ
معانا من قبل حتى ما نعرف الكتابة حتى ولا
القراءة لما كان البشر عايشين حياة
بدائية تمامًا، ومن الفضول ده اللي بان
عندنا أوي، كان فضول حب السماء أو النظر
للسماء، زمان البشر، أجدادنا، على فكرة
لحد وقت قريب، يعني عايز اقولكوا لحد
مثلا من خمسين ستين سنة بس كان الجو مفيش
التلوث اللي إحنا عايشينه دلوقتي، مكنش في
الأضواء الكثيرة اللي إحنا بنستخدمها في
حضارتنا الحديثة دلوقتي، فكان الليل رائع
جدًا جدًا .
بنقعد بالليل.
طبعا مافيش كهرباء أصلاً في معظم مناطق
العالم وبالتالي الناس في الليل تسليتها ايه
مافيش كهرباء يعني مافيش تلفزيون
يعني مافيش إنترنت،
يعني مافيش،
كل تسليته بالليل إنه يقعد يتفرج على السماء
الجميلة الرائعة، وطبعًا أهم سؤال سأله
لنفسه وكان فضوله ليه قوي هو أيه الدبان
المنور في السجادة الزرقاء اللي فوق ده
وقعد الإنسان
فترة طويلة جدا عمال يدور هو إيه ده؟
إيه النقط المدورة اللامعة اللي موجودة
في سماء الليل؟
طبعا إحنا عايشين دلوقتي في الحياة الحديثة
في المدن اللي مليانه تلوث
مابنشوفش كلام بالجمال ده،
لو حد طلع للصحراء، بات ليله
بس في الصحراء هيشوف
قد إيه السماء فعلاً بتشد وفعلا مبتقدرش
تسيبها و تنام مثلاً.
إحنا لما نبيت في الصحراء
فعلا الواحد مبيبقاش ليه نفس ينام،
الشكل ده، اللي الإنسان البدائي
تخيل إن دي مجرد قبة فوق الأرض اللي إحنا
عايشين عليها، ومحطوط عليها نقط منورة
ولأن الحاجة دي فوق وعالية وبعيده عن إيديه
فبدأ ينسج عليها الأساطير و في الغالب
الأساطير دي ارتبطت بقوة أعلى منه،
فبقي يشبهها بإن دي آلهة
أو مرتبطة بالآلهة وإن دي
اللي بتتحكم في مصائرنا وإن دي حاجة أكبر
وأقوى مننا، وبدأ ينسج عليها الأساطير في
الحضارات المختلفة بأشكال مختلفة
أو بثقافات مختلفة.
وبعدين مع التطور العلمي الحديث
اللي إحنا وصلناله
بدأنا نعرف معلومات أكثر وبدأنا ندرك
الكون أكثر .
بدأنا نعرف أن النقط المنورة في السماء
مثلاً معظمها نجوم أو شموس زي الشمس
بتاعتنا، وأن كل شمس من دول حواليها الكواكب
بتاعتها، وأن الكون لا نهائي.
إحنا مش مجرد قبة كده بتحيط بينا
ومرسوم عليها
أو منور فيها شوية لمبات كده نقط منورة .
لا ده كون لانهائي بأبعاد خيالية
وبعدد من الأجرام السماوية، كبير جدًا.
و إحنا مجرد فسفوسة صغيرة،
ذرة صغيرة في الكون ده
كوكب بيدور حوالين نجم رئيسي
وكمان حوالينا كواكب
لما بدأ الإنسان يتطلع إلي ده،
الأول كنا نستقبل المعلومة
بالتليسكوبس وبالأجهزة
المختلفة عشان نحاول نفهم إيه ده، وبعدين
الطموح وشغف المعرفة لما زاد، بدأنا عايزين
نروح إلي ده، عايزين نطلع بره حدود الأرض
بتاعتنا ونروح أماكن مختلفة
لحد ما نجح الإنسان إنه يحقق ده.
سنة تسعة وستين لأول مرة كان بشر ينزل على
جرم سماوي ثاني
وهو القمر.
فاكرين قصة القمر طبعًا
اللي هي في ناس لسه بتشكك فيها
لحد النهاردة.
كل الكلام ده غير علمي عشان بس نبقى
عارفين. وصل الإنسان للقمر
وبعد كده رحلات الفضاء تطورت وتوسعت جدًا
ويمكن وصلنا دلوقتي لنهاية المجموعة الشمسية
ولكن بدون بشر بس مسبارات بتطلع لأن
احتياج البشر الحقيقة كتير شوية.
يعني عشان ابعت كائن حي يسافر في الفضاء
إحنا في احتياجات كتيرة لينا اعتدناها أو
حياتنا محتاجاها موجودة على الأرض ولكن مش
موجودة في الفضاء والاحتياجات دي منها حاجات
إحنا عارفينها مباشرة
زي المياه، الأكل، الشرب والتنفس.
كل ده أول ما أسأل أي طفل صغير هيقول اه
لازم هواء ومياه
وأكل عشان نقدر نعيش فترات طويلة
وفي حاجات هعندي عليها النهاردة كده نكتشف
حاجات
إحنا مش متخيلين إن نقصها ممكن يأثر
فينا أو ممكن يضايقنا، طبعًا أول دستنيشن أو
أول تارجت بعد القمر كنا بنفكر فيه كان هو
كوكب المريخ.
إيه المشاكل اللي ممكن تقبلنا لو
أنا عايز أروح للمريخ بحياة، ببشر.
أبعت بشر للمريخ و يعيشوا على
المريخ، إيه المشاكل اللي ممكن تقابلنا؟
عندنا نوعين من المشاكل الرئيسية،
نوع في الطريق للمريخ
إحنا هما سافر لمسافة والمسافات دي علي فكرة
بتاخد وقت زي ما إحنا شايفين
كده، أنا ما أقدرش أطلع للمريخ في خط
مستقيم ليه؟ لو طلعت في خط مستقيم
أنا هامشي مباشرة عكس اتجاه
الجاذبية الشمسية، ده محتاج طاقة هائلة جدًا
فا إحنا بنعمل إيه؟ بنمشي في مدار
كأننا بناخد مدار
حوالين الشمس، مش الأرض بتلف حوالين
الشمس في الجرافيتي؟
والمريخ بيلف في الجرافيتي؟
فإحنا بناخد المسبار اللي بيطلع
بياخد مدار كأنه بقي مدار حوالين
الشمس بس بدل ما يبقى مدار
ثابت، بعده ثابت، يبدأ يوسع شوية شوية شوية
شوية لحد ما يقابل المريخ.
المريخ نفسه بيلف والأرض نفسها بتتحرك،
فتخيلوا الدقة اللي محتاجين نعملها
كأنه في حد كان بيشبه كده
بيقول كأن في رصاصة طايرة وأنا
بنشن عليها برصاصة وعايزها تيجي فيها.
أنتم متخيلين تتعمل إزاي؟ أنا لازم أعرف
سرعة الرصاصة ومسارها ، واللي طالع من عندي
بادئ بسرعة قد إيه ومساره يمشي إزاي
عشان بعد قد إيه يوصل يقابل ده
فتخيلوا عشان آخد مسار كبير زي ده
الرحلة للمريخ تستغرق مننا حاليًا، في حدود
التكنولوجيا الحالية بتاعة البشر حوالي
8 شهور.
8 شهور يعني أنا هقعد البشر
عايز كل واحد منكم يتخيل أنه هيقعد في أوضة
كده 2 متر في 2 متر 8 شهور.
مبيشوفش حد غير الاثنين ثلاثة اللي معاه في
الرحلة، يتواصل باللاسلكي بنسبة تأخير.
تخيلوا لما حد بيبعت لحد رسالة
النهاردة ومابيردش عليه.
إنت فين مابتردش عليا ليه؟ أصلاً لو أنا
وصلت عند المريخ وببعت رسالة للأرض
الرسالة تاخد حوالى ربع ساعة
لحد ما توصل الأرض.
يعني أقول صباح الخير، أستني ربع ساعة توصل
للأرض، وبعدين هو يرد فتاخد ربع ساعة تاني
عشان توصل للمريخ.
عشان بس يقولي صباح الخير
خدنا نص ساعة.
المسافات بقت كبيرة والتعامل معاها
بقي مختلف
أثناء ما أنا ماشي هنا، في عندي مشكلتين
رئيسيتين أول حاجة: الكوزمك ردياشن
أو الإشعاع الكوني أو
الإشعاع الضار اللي بالأساس جاي من الشمس،
الشمس بتاعتنا دي هي عبارة عن مفاعل نووي
ضخم جدًا.
بيحصل فيه إندماج نووي وبيطلع الطاقة
الهائلة ده.
التفاعل النووي ده بيطلع شوية مواد
ضارة كتيرة جدًا.
أولاً بيطلع إشعاع ضار زي أشعة غاما
وأشعة فوق بنفسجية وكده وأشعة إكس،
أشعة فوق بنفسجية .
ثانيًا بيطلع تشارجد بارتيكلز أو
جسيمات مشحونة
اللي هي جسيمات دون الذرية زي البروتونز
والإلكترونز.
كل ده بيطلع من الشمس.
الاه، طب وإحنا هنا على الأرض إيه
اللي بيحمينا منها؟ بيحمينا منها حاجتين.
الموجات الكهرومغناطيسية دي
بيحمينا منها الغلاف الجوي للأرض.
طبقة الأوزون اللي كنا بنسمع عنها كتير،
بتمنع الموجات اللي ترددها عالي
زي الغاما رايز
والإكس رايز والألترا فايلوت وأشعة فوق
بنفسجية وبعدين الغلاف المغناطيسي للأرض.
الأرض لها كمان غلاف مغناطيسي، حقل
مغناطيسي بيحيط بالأرض.
ده بيخلي الجسيمات المشحونة تنحرف
بدل ما تبقي جايه عالأرض تنحرف وتلف
من حوالين
الأرض وتبعد عننا.
لما نطلع بره الغلاف ده،
هنبقى في الهواء مفيش حماية، ولو اتعرضنا
للكوزمك ردياشن
كبشر أو ككائنات حية لفترة طويلة،
ده أحد الحاجات المضرة بينا جدًا.
بتعمل تعمل خلايا سرطانية
في جسم الكائن الحي،
وبالتالي إحنا كده بنبدأ نموت،
نفقد خلايانا بعد وقت معين.
دي مشكلة كبيرة عايزينلها حل، في مشكلة
تانية إن إحنا طول فترة الرحلة ال 8 شهور دي
هنبقي فيما يسمى بالمايكرو جرافيتي.
إحنا عايشين على الأرض، في جاذبية للأرض
بتشدنا لتحت، متوافقين معاها جسمنا اعتاد
وجودها، فمثلاً لما بيتحرك كدة بننقاوم هذه
الجاذبية وعضلاتنا بتقوى
تخيل لو قعدنا في انعدام جاذبية 8 شهور،
بيبدأ يحصل شوية حاجات.
مارك كيلي اللي إحنا حاطين صورته ده،
ده حد رائد فضاء أمريكي، حبوا يجربوا لو
الانسانة قعد فترة طويلة كده عشان
لو بعتنا حد المريخ
فقعد في محطة الفضاء الدولية
حوالي سنة كاملة.
عشان يشوفوا تأثير ده عليه إيه، في تأثيرات
بيولوجية كتير بيدرسها بقي الاطباء دلوقتي
من أهمها أن بيحصل ضمور في العضلات.
حد شاف رائد فضاء وهو راجع، أول ما نزل من
رحلة فضاء قعد على محطة الفضاء الدولية
مثلًا 3 شهور، أول ما بينزل بيبقي شكله إيه؟
شاف منظر زي كده فالتليفزيون ولا حاجه،
بنلاقيهم واخدينه علي نقالة، تخيلوا واخدينه
علي نقاله، مش قادر يمشي اه، واحد قعد
3 شهور
في انعدام جاذبية فا يجي في
الجاذبية يحس كأن حد رابطه بحبل كده
وشاده، حاطت تقالات و شاده عالأرض
فعلًا مبيبقاش قادر يمشي، وخصوصًا رغم
إن رواد الفضاء
اللي بيقعدوا فترات طويلة بيعملولهم
تجارب، يعني تمرينات
كتيرة بيقعد يعمل تمرينات كتيرة
عشن الجهاز العضلي و كده،
إنما كل ده في الآخر بينزل مش زي الجاذبية
الطبيعية فا مابيقدرش يتحرك تحت
تأثير الجاذبية حسب المدة بقي ممكن تبقي
بعد بضعة ساعات لبضعة أيام، تخيلوا
نقعد كام يوم كده
فا إحنا لو بعتنا حد هيقعد 8
شهور هيحصله إيه؟
طب نقدر نعكس؟
نعمل جاذبية صناعية مثلًا؟
دي أحد الأبحاث المهمة جدًا
اللي إحنا محتاجين نركز عليها وإحنا
بنعمل رحلات للفضاء.
لما هنوصل هناك على كوكب المريخ، طب وصلنا،
نزلنا أرض زي الصحراء عندنا حلو جدًا.
هواء حلو جدا.
هنعرف نعيش كده من غير حاجة؟ لا.
أولًا مافيش أكسجين فا محتاجين نتنفس
هنجهز أكسجين أو هناخده معانا.
ثانيًا في نقطة مهمة جدًا، ويمكن لو حد شاف
فيلم ذا مارشين
الراجل ده لما حب يزرع، مراحش زرع في تربة
موجودة وفيه هواء وفيه ثاني اكسيد الكربون
والنبات مابيحتاجش أكتلر من كده، مش كده؟
ورغم كده راح زرع جوة الاوضة
جوة بيئة السكن اللي
عاملينها أو الوحدات المقفولة اللي عاملينها
ليه كدة؟ عشان درجة الحرارة دي حاجة.
طبعًا لو درجة الحرارة تحت التجمد،
النباتات معظمها مش هايقدر يعيش.
حاجة تاني مهمة جدًا وحاجة موجودة في
حياتنا وإحنا مش حاسين بيها
وحاجة
إحتياجنا ليها
أكثر من احتياجنا للأكسجين مش كدة؟
ممكن يبقي في حاجة كدة؟ لو سألت أي واحد
أنت ممكن، إيه أكتر حاجة ماتقدرش
تستغنى عنها؟
تموت لو استغنيت عنها، هقولك الأكسجين.
لو ماتنفستش
ده أنا في بضع دقائق،
شوية دقائق ممكن أموت، مش كده؟
تخيلوا أن في حاجة لو فقدناها
لأقل من دقيقة نموت.
ومش حاسين بده لإن إحنا متواجدين
جواها دايمًا
الحاجة دي هي إيه؟ هي الضغط الجوي،
الإير بريشر
الهواء بتاع الأرض اللي عامل غلاف
جوي ده، فوقينا
لمسافة كبيرة أوي بيوصل إلى 100
كيلو بدرجة كثيفة وبعدين بيبدأ يقل
كثافته تدريجيًا، عامل ضغط علينا
الهواء و الماية، الحاجات دي اللي
هي الموائع، الفلودز
وزنها بيشكل ضغط على أي حاجة بتسبح جواها.
إحنا كده
جوة الغلاف الجوي، هومحيط بينا، بيعمل ضغط
علينا، الضغط ده بصورة تقريبية تشبيهية كده
اللي إحنا أخدناه في المدرسة زمان وبنكتب
76 سنتيمتر زئبق.
يعني إيه؟ أحس بيه إزاي ده؟
كأن كل واحد سنتيمتر من مساحة سطح جسمنا
شايل واحد كيلو غرام، متخيلين؟
أنا عايزكوا النهاردة كده
تجربوا ده، تروحوا عند أي حد ببيع الخضار
ولا فاكهة وناخد السنجة
اللي هي واحد كيلو اللي بيوزنها ونحطها
علي صباعنا كده.
عقلة الصباع تقريبًا مساحتها سنتيمتر مربع
ولنتخيل الضغط دة، يعني كل سنتيمتر من مساحة
سطح جسمنا مضغوط عليه بواحد كيلو غرام؟
اه
وإحنا مش حاسين بيه ليه؟ عشان إحنا
نشأنا تحت الضغط ده
فا مش متخيلين أو مش
متجاوبين معاه أو متفاعلين معاه،
الضغط ده لما بيزيد بنقدر
نتحمله لحدود معينة زي ما بيعمل الغواصين.
طب الفضاء مفهوش هواء، مفهوش ضغط جوي،
الضغط الجوي صفر.
تخيلوا لو إنسان طلع من الضغط الجوي بتاع
الأرض مباشرة
لزيرو ضغط جوي، يموت
في أقل من دقيقة.
يموت إزاي؟ كل سوائل الجسم
هتتبخر، يبقي حتة خشبة
في أقل من دقيقة، أسرع من احتياجه للأكسجين.
فلو حد مثلًا في مركبة فضاء ووقع براها
ولا حاجة، ميقلقش أن هو يموت مخنوق
أصلًا هيموت في أقل من دقيقة من قبل ما يموت
أو من قبل ما يحس أن في نقص في الأكسجين.
بتبقي طبعًا درجات الحرارة والتجمد وكده.
طيب هو المريخ
ضغطه الجوي قد إيه؟ أقل من واحد في ال 100
من الضغط الجوي للأرض.
ينهار أبيض يعني إحنا مش هنقدر
نعيش على المريخ كده؟
زي ما إحنا واقفين علي الأرض؟
لا، لازم يا إما بدلة فضاء
يا إما داخل كبينة مجهزة
زي ما فيها أكسجين زي ما فيها ضغط يعادل
الضغط، لدرجة إن إحنا لما هنيجي
نطلع من الكبينة ده لابس البدلة بتاعت
الفضاء، وعايز أطلع من الكبينة أمشي على
سطح المريخ، بدخل الأول غرفة في الوسط اسمها
غرفة معادلة الضغط، أطلع جوة الغرفة دي
ضغطها زي الضغط الخارجي وبعدين ألبس البدلة
فيها و أروح قافل عن الكبينة الرئيسية،
وينزل الضغط فيها لحد ما يساوي الضغط
الخارجي وبعدين يفتح.
عارفين لو فتح الباب وهو
من غير ما يعمل معادلة الضغط،
أولا كل حاجة جوة الكبينة هتطير للخارج
فتتحرك من الضغط الأكثر للضغط الأقل،
تتشفط لبرة كده، فهنا يحصل
تعرض لفقدان الضغط مرة واحدة.
لو هو مش لابس بدلة الفضاء،
يموت في أقل من دقيقة. تخيلوا دي حاجة إحنا
أصلًا مكناش عاملين حساب كده.
إحنا محتاجين الضغط الجوي ده، طب
هنعمله إزاي؟
طبعنا أنا الأكسجين ممكن اجيبه
من ثاني أكسيد الكربون مش كده؟ خدت بشكل
كيميائي بسهولة جدًا هقدر استخلص
أكسجين من ثاني أكسيد الكربون.
أولًا الموضوع صعب،
ثانيًا محتاج فترةزمنية طويلة، قد تصل لو
هعملها بعمليات
تدريجية، ده كوكب.
أنا مش بتكلم إن أنا هزود كثافة الغلاف
الجوي لمدينة القاهرة مثلًا
أنا بتكلم على كوكب
كامل يساوي تقريبًا ربع حجم كوكب الأرض.
فالموضوع محتاج شغل كتير أوي أو هنفضل
بقي علي المريخ دايمًا.
أي حركة، خارج على سطح
المريخ لابسين البدل بتاعة الفضاء وقاعدين
محبوسين جوه البدل بتاعة الفضاء، ورغم كده
في تجربة معمولة إن إحنا هنروح نودي بشر
للمريخ، محطوط
تقريبًا دلوقتي إنهم يوصلوا
سنة 2026.
تخيلوا البشر دول اللي هما أول تجربة هتروح
من أهم الحاجات إن إحنا مش هنعرف نرجعهم،
يعني رايحين ون واي ترب، هنروح
ننزلهم على المريخ
انتوا مش هنعرف نجيبكوا في حدود التكنولوجيا
بتاعتنا الحالية، ليه الكلام ده؟
متخيلين عشان أطلع من المريخ تاني أنا محتاج
طاقة قد إيه ومحتاج منصه، تخيلوا الصاروخ
اللي بيطلع من الأرض بس بيطلع قمر صناعي
تقريبًا 80 % من كتلته الوقود
اللي بيطلع بيه.
أنا عشان أطلع بره جاذبية الكوكب محتاج
طاقة هائلة جدًا
ومحتاج منصة إطلاق ومحتاج، كل الكلام ده
هروح اوديه لحد المريخ إزاي؟
ده كتل رهيبة جدًا.
فأول تجربة هتطلع ناس
للمريخ هيبقى ون واي ترب.
إحنا هنوديكوا وننزلكوا ونديكم مقومات
الحياة وإزاي تعيشوا
وعيشوا بقي لحد ما نعرف نتواصل معاكوا تاني.
التجربة دي طلبوا ليها متطوعين.
تخيلوا على مستوى الكرة الأرضية تقدم مئات
الآلاف للتطوع ون واي ترب ومش هيرجع تاني.
عمللهم اختبارات، صفوهم علي 100 واحد
جاهزين تمامًا أنهم يطلعوا في أي وقت،
ساعة ما يتحدد
معاد الرحلة، أكتر 4 جاهزين هيطلعوا في أول
رحلة، وبعدين يطلعوا على دفعات، 4
منهم 1 مصري منهم 2
عرب، واحد مصري وواحدة عراقية، مختارين
من ضمن 100 اللي هيروحوا للمريخ ون واي ترب
في بيئة صعبة جدًا علينا، مختلفة جدًا عننا
بيئة معلومة لينا بنسبة معينة، ولكن لسه
فيها الكثير من المجهول، وفيها الكثير من
المعوقات، لكن هو ده الإنسان، هو
ده فضول المعرفة والطموح.
إن هو دايمًا يتطور ودايمًا يستكشف اكتر،
ودايمًا يروح يسبر أغوار أكثر عمقًا
من الكون بتاعنا.
كل ما يبقى عندنا الفضول المعرفي ده
والطموح لأننا نحقق المزيد،
كل ما هنقدر نطلع بره حدودنا اللي إحنا
رسمناها لنفسنا
الأول، ونحقق أهداف وغايات
أكبر بكتير جدًا.
ماتسيبوش طموحكم في أي وقت ولا فضولكم
للمعرفة، شكرًا.